je disais que ce soirre un bon soir pour
faire l'amour tu crois
pas c'est une idée intéressante mais VO
est St le nouvel opéra avance
bien discussions on doitevoir un premier
jet partition dans semaines que çaours
j've malheureusement un blage créatif en
CE
non
mal il il s totalement écroulé après son
dernier
op
je besoin d'un bon marche
Ilis on par je continue de vous imaginer
nu je ne sais pas si vous voulez que je
vous donne plus de détails
non je paris que chacune de ces
personnes a une histoire digne d'un
opéra l tu fais quoi je pilote un bateau
remorqueur re de mauvaises mains ce
bateau est une arme
mortelle j'ai accro au romantisme comme
tout le monde non on m'a arrêté pour
harcèlement j'ai dû suivre une thérapie
et je suis pas censé faire ça
j'ai du mal à croire ce qui est arrivé
c'est elle qui m'a séduit une sorcière
la capitaine desaxès qui attire les
hommes sur son remorqueur pour les tuer
et les manger vous êtes un foutu g où
êtesvous aller pêcher ça j'étais
vraiment en colère contre toi et là je
découvre que je suis tamuse quoi Steven
je te quitterai
jamais j'adore frotter la propreté la S
de la sainteté pendant que mes patients
parlent j'imagine que j'entre dans leur
tête avec une bouteille de désinfectant
et que je fais un GR ménage
ta capitaine de bateau est venue me voir
je suis amoureuse non non tu refuses
d'avouer que j'ai eu un effet magique
sur toi mon imagination a inventé
l'histoire mon talent a composer la
musique est-ce que je sache tu ne tues
pas les hommes pour les dévorer et bien
pas
encore tu sais que je peux pas résister
à une belle histoire d'amour même si je
suis pas
[Musique]
concerné